hallo mein Name ist Luca meine Damen und
Herren ich mache heute einen couple Quiz
mit meiner Freundin Sandra da ist kein
Kaffee Quiz wir haben von Christian
abgeguckt wir haben jetzt gegenseitig 13
Fragen über einen selber aufgeschrieben
und der andere muss sie einfach
beantworten ja
schon so lange kennen und Kappeln sind
würde ich sagen
was soll mein erstes Haustier und der
Name das ist ziemlich easy ah Shiva euer
Hund ist ja das Haus von Michelle also
nicht dein Haustier der Hamster Ralf ist
auch nicht dein erstes Haus gewesen weil
du hattest ja schon mal ein Hamster und
der hieß Siemens nein mein erstes Tier
war ein Meerschweinchen und das ist
deine Oma getötet hat gewesen
ja keine Ahnung wieso hast du solche
Fragen ich habe sehr gute Frage wie
lange ist mein Schwanz
Fußball
habe ich zuerst in der Wohnung gewohnt
oder im Haus ich habe doch gesagt ach so
okay ich dachte du meinst nach Köln
gezogen
weil das wusste ich ja dass du erst da
unten in der Kellerwohnung warst und
danach ins Haus gezogen ist
ich glaube du hast tatsächlich als
erstes in einer Wohnung gewohnt richtig
ich auch ja
Hühnerstall bin ich kurz oder
weitsichtig
du also weitsichtig bedeutet man kann
weit sehen ne ich glaube du bist ein
weitsichtiger ich bin kurzsichtig ah
okay ich kann Sachen die sehr nah von
meinem Gesicht sind kann ich sehr gut
sehen aber Sachen das bedeutet ich habe
extra noch mal gegoogelt okay ich bin
kurzsichtig welche Sportart war meine
erste
[Musik]
also
ich halte das hier immer noch für
scammen aber die Wanderer macht er was
sie schon alle Sportarten gemacht
[Musik]
Fußball Basketball Tennis Kunstturnen
und da wurde wieder rausgeschmissen weil
die meinte ich wäre zu kindisch sehr
gefragt hat wie groß bin ich in
Zentimeter
193 cm 94
dass mein Schwanzlänge gerade gesehen
was war mein erster Notendurchschnitt
den ich je bekommen habe in der Art der
dritten Klasse in der dritten Klasse
also es muss etwas mit einer zwei vorne
gewesen wenn meine eins hattest du noch
nie gut gemerkt
2,3 2,0 was ist meine
lieblingssockenmarke
dran Laser
lange Haare
wie viele Tattoos habe ich
[Musik]
vierte weggegangen
was trinke ich wenn ich müde bin
[Musik]
Wasser
wie heißt meine beiden Cousinen
Michelle und Alex Schwester
[Musik]
ich weiß es Asthma
korrekt erste Frage richtig welche
Zigarettenmarke habe ich als allererstes
geraucht
Lucky Luke
gar nicht so schlecht wie heißt die denn
Lucky strikes ohne Zusätze Lucky Strike
ja aber egal
was ist mein Standard Frühstück
boah wie soll ich sagen
mit Brot und Avocado richtig
schön Brot drauf
[Musik]
ein Tag später
welche Pizza bestelle ich immer
[Musik]
wir haben noch nie zusammen Pizza
bestellt glaube ich Salami
thun
wenn man so nennen kann weil ich habe
jetzt keine Person zu der ich so
wirklich mein Leben lang aufgeschaut
habe um dieser Person
Aussehen danke
von amerikanischer Blog aus New York so
seine Motivation sein Hassel einfach
andere wer war mein allererster Luca
nein ja danke danke
also Julius
wie lang war ich mit Julius
wieso hatte mal die komplette
Grundschule wegen mir frei
gelaufen
in welchem Alter war mein erster Flug
so viel wie du fliegst mit 0 würde ich
sagen
mit welcher Kamera nehme ich meine
Videos auf
mit einer LG oder wie
das ist mein Sternzeichen Fisch
du bist so Fisch du nicht nein
keine Ahnung
was ist meine Nationalität
ich habe noch prozentuale leicht anderen
Nationalität
[Musik]
nein was denn
mein Handy Nokia
Sony Ericsson nein ein LG in Gold
mit diese Klappe nein wie viele Freunde
hatte ich bereits in meinem ganzen Leben
vier fünf geboren
nackt ja nee also war das ein
Kaiserschnitt
ja weil das jetzt normaler Schnitt war
das letzte Geburt im Krankenhaus oder
Kaiserschnitt in der Bar nee ganz normal
ja im Krankenhaus okay würden wir an der
Stelle das heutige Video jetzt auch Ben
meine Damen und Herren wenn euch die ein
oder andere Sache hier vorne
okay